yeah hello welcome to this broadcast I'm
late one minute so i hope you yeah you
not have run away yeah because I'm
unusually late usually I'm right on the
right time just on the minute but I had
some issues here dad to resolve first
okay I hope you all had a good start to
the week and for me the this first day
of the week the Monday will end with the
show I hope so i'm going to kick off
with a new game yeah you gotta a car by
in the house one of the most frequent
opponents yeah hello to all of you in
the twit sheds like my Ponzi people and
Hobgoblin triple checker who's orlando
all the regulars are there so i tried
the london system and let's see where
that leads us i'm still going to try to
be a bit ambitious with c4 not play ac3
bait setup that is just too lame okay
hmm alright seems he wants to pin me
with 94 stuff yeah 92 is just too meek
so I go Knight c3 yellow also to made
grinder and also regular on that show
okay so it seems he wants to go with 95
here hmm our queen 85 so I really have
to get my development going here well
let's cancel
get out of the pin it's not a very
comfortable position he's definitely
completely okay here so what now maybe
90 x yellow also too kay slay six yeah
everything's good on my end had a good
monday yeah this this kind of position
is certainly okay for him but at least
my development seems fine probably take
on c6 if he if he lets me or take d5 I
would probably yeah this is also
impossible but okay I've got the B file
now so there is some kind of dynamic
compensation hello to igniting ideas
no I didn't order any chess books for
the holidays I still have a couple of
books that I should try to yeah check
out Hearst ok I think night b5 496 it
makes quite some sense trying to
activate the night that way 96 looking
at the beep on yeah and he lks got 94
that's a bad that's bad I didn't didn't
think about this 95 94 ok so let's drop
back am I going to play some crazy stuff
today hmm I don't know hey I feel like
playing normal stuff
okay so 96 one says something else I can
also take what 96 looks right okay so
hmm ok a Quincy for doesn't do much
maybe here attack the night I currently
I don't have anymore dual commentary
matches in the works I mean not not in a
concrete way I know that some of you um
I think pointed the idea or to sign the
Williams and he said that he could that
that that is up for it so this is
something that would be fun to do but we
have no no I concrete date set up or
anything like that it's just that the
general idea could could be could be
interesting so here cannot invade
unfortunately i would like to mmm maybe
here to take it 65 i'm going to do a to
broadcast of the london chefs classics
yes for the icc on the 6th and on the on
the tenth of december okay
yes I'm Williams likes to push the H
porn Harry as he calls it yeah so I
definitely have to it will be careful
them but we would see when this match is
going to happen ok I don't have anything
great yeah I think I can shake it seven
but it doesn't help I think I need to
try to pry open this ok so he doesn't
mind to open hmm yeah Bishop cheeks I
wonder i am that since it doesn't look
good from a from a structural point of
view but it's very active bishop age six
is not working unfortunately
hmm not quite sure what I should do
yeah looking forward to them London jazz
classics always those those those
tournaments are always fun to watch okay
it's trying to go for 95 so is there
some way here my structure is terrible
really is do I get something going here
hmm i don't i don't see anything
brilliant he's got rocked his seven in
the works it's not good maybe look up to
the five we've got 97 though now it
doesn't maybe this is still okay
going going at the a to the a pond but
he can go away five I guess now like
it's better him
and I'm not having a good the time
situation is also oh it's surprising t
that you took them
out for 96 in case of King c5
hmm yeah it's a bit off on age six yeah
I I have to admit that but I don't see a
big problem at the moment the time of
course but the position is fine I think
b3 night takes is pretty pretty clear
draw okay it's a total draw after night
before but I was down on time he
unfortunately I have to get get into
into the Blitz mode again so I don't
think that Kramnik is good youtube
channel dr. lecture okay grigor grigor
off okay I hope it's not a cannibal so
we got a king's there now I thought
that's not a king's indian hello to the
chess wolf also and 25 called five card
draw and to just well yeah many new
people in the chat that's good yeah
grigor grigor off what about d5 here's
animals I never saw this particular
position looks completely uncovered and
biggest dick is also a round of Monty
Python fame probably nights is six year
just trade the horse stuff okay so he's
basically giving this 4 p-7
hmm ok I don't know it this is this kind
of lines and sometimes tricky to says if
they are just equal on if there's some
kind of small pool for four wide okay
hello to the math doc
so what happens here I've got this
covered maybe go here to attack a to
know why don't I haven't yet studied a
new line against the main line Spanish I
want to study the the brayer from the
bolo gun book but have not yet get
gotten around to it um maybe I will do
so over the holiday in three to four
weeks when I'm when are we when i'll be
teaching less many of my students will
have Christmas celebrations anyway so I
probably get to do that Queen to be
three sure
hmm this is a drawers there's a bit
worse for me oh yeah it should be a draw
I don't I don't think yeah maybe I've
play all I guess I don't know if he's
online at the moment so on its cover
seven life of brian is illegal in Wales
that sounds crazy
michael says mr. williger's manages to
make chances exciting as tic-tac-toe
you're right but you haven't seen the
most boring game ever against them it
will be released in a couple of days
okay what is he doing now checking me
there that doesn't do much so I'm going
to go to see to how to learn chess best
hmm well there's a couple of ways to do
it I mean the it's certainly very
helpful to play as many games as
possible having fun that's the most
important thing if you don't have fun
with your studies you're not going to be
a very successful in the end doing
tactics at lower levels just make sense
learn to calculate lines properly those
kind of things and it wasn't a you can
also watch my channel yes it's a good
mixture of entertainment and and some
some instruction if that wasn't a cattle
and I think it was some kind of Queens
gambit that I had against mr. what he
goes so I'm going to check here and he
will take down then going to offer draw
here this is kind of yeah this is really
not much going on so let's do a new game
playing kazoo let's go before ok I will
do something wild if he goes along yeah
what is he doing um I could play be
three or something crazy against the
French forgot that hello to Lapland
Nessus I'm not sure that's probably
wrong pronunciation from Mexico
so I'm going to place I'd Lonnie with
the capture on d5 yeah it's not very
well I should have played be three on
move to I'm sorry I actually I actually
forgot about it that this is a line that
I sometimes play and it's it is kind of
interesting what is happening here he
plays night Bishop to a five hmm maybe
just 92
and maybe you can play Bishop takes d4
huh okay so I have to make a gambit out
of that it's of course it wasn't planned
but yeah that and then it that looks
even somewhat dangerous it's not
completely completely without ideas oh I
didn't see that one coming o Queen g5
weird a prediction for the London chest
classics of course Carly's cards as we
win he's really he should win the
tournament again the best line in the
French tarish went black plates 55 hmm
hmm I don't know there's something great
really it depends a lot on the sub
variation what what happens next yeah
hmm
is that so bad
it's got a six coming huh I wanted to go
g4 but now I recognize that night h4 is
pretty awkward what am I doing here g4
night edge for it's pretty weird no it's
pretty bad um
the bangko as a surprise weapon hmm
maybe but you have to if you want to
play the banco as a surprise weapon you
have to play it against the right
opponent the problem with the bank we
said some lines are somewhat somewhat
shaky for black slightly shaky at least
and if you play it as a surprise weapon
it means that you're not going to their
that you're not having studied it like
for ages and I sorry for ages is wrong
but you haven't put in lots of time lots
lots of work and this can be a problem
yeah if both both sides are kind of
making things up then I think why does
often um yeah better or if white know
something special if he has got
something prepared you will be in
trouble I think the Banco is an opening
that you can you should rather if you
want to play it in the first place you
should specialize in and not yeah so
much go go for it as a as a surprise
weapon it's more of a specialist kind of
opening where you have to yeah where you
have to be sure about your your lines
wanted to provoke that be five not sure
that there was a good idea
in the banco y term has a couple of
interesting lines the the current
fashion is that a four line but and lots
of white lots of black players avoided
altogether so not sure how often you
would get it on the board so is there
some kind of reared checkmate that i can
maybe get going some checkmates have to
play for Trixie rb2 I was thinking hmm
you can promote you a night queen TX is
made rooked is 64 made very cheap trick
I have to admit that but can try you can
promote for a night though but King
before I sruti six mate is a pretty
pretty substantial threat huh it's got a
five and I'm losing probably but it's um
it's still kind of funny maybe it's
looking for that menu how to promote to
a night there we got under promotion
again Luke t6 made so I'm grabbing stuff
and here is there some way now it's hard
to get to the b5 porn unfortunately
so I asked Nancy fortune hmm let's not
good
yeah before it's going to win I guess
maybe I can go like d5 but should be
five check yeah that's a evo repertoire
series coming up by John Shaw on quality
chest but it seems to take quite a long
while I think the reason is that Shaw is
also doing them editing and he's always
busy with other people's books oh man
what a bad position can I get that
pawned somehow I mean at least that porn
for Bishop would be good I don't see how
I am just lost them ah man bet start him
bad start to that event no resigned whoo
that was bad that was really bad bad
game
yeah they also have that Neji efore
repertoire that would be would be for
the super theoretical guys very
difficult to deal with for normal people
why is nims which my system a bad book
in the eyes of a lot of chess into this
and why yeah there's a reason well it's
like 100 years old almost and lots of
things have happened in the meantime
lots of things that names which is is
saying are interesting and correct even
nowadays but there are also many things
that are far too single-minded let's say
and what we shouldn't forget is that he
played his some stuff against many very
read players and he could basically what
he did there he tried to prove his ideas
his theories it's all good but if you
play it against super weak or position
you can prove any everything yeah I mean
you could play the the total absolute
total nonsense and you would still win
and you know some things that he has in
there are good but some things are not
there just outdated and I think that my
system is an interesting book to to go
for if you are a little bit stronger if
you want to get a good picture of how
chest developed over the over the
decades but as a learning tool I think
it's some a bit outdated
okay so 95 or queen h4 looks like a
spectacular move that is close to
working
it's probably going f three down I
wonder I can also go quinacrine am queen
g5 stuff I mean
I wasn't sure yet if I can do something
drastic already hi to stylee are you a
fan of Fiona's style n tony Saudi five
what about this I can go if I've but
that's normally not what I want in this
position I'd rather want more pieces in
the game Knight f6 takes Knight g4 maybe
let's try that
it's definitely not an easy position for
wide to play d 5 is a good move now edit
blocks the the diagonal and the finals
oops wrong hello also regular viewer
here yeah I'm going for Knight g4 here
and see how he defends against that
f-for yes so a couple of interesting
ideas I mean just going back as probably
right just threatening 93 I don't think
crazy stuff would work don't have enough
attacking power but night takes 23 now
is a pretty pretty substantial threat it
looks good yeah I think that is a good
position for black so now i can
sacrifice on g3 that's definitely close
to working Nyjah for is more of a
technical move it's not bad yeah I think
that's actually pretty good h2 is
attacked what is he doing if it takes
I'm threatening queen age 3m and my
knight on e4 is a monster maybe I could
have taken on g3 but this is just an
excellent position for black so I don't
have to sacrifice it's just a great
position as it is okay now i can think
of sacrifices again but i think Queen
age 3 is just a good move or not
Queen 839 h4 maybe hmm Jeremy now can
take that for great compensation but
maybe I had something better 923 here
takes Queen takes Knight g2 will check
on h2 king F Troop g8 hmmm it's pretty
strong but just taking all that stuff is
also good and now what now I have to pry
open that long diagonal like this maybe
or the IC having a threat route d3 is
that a threat my queen is not having
many squares ok ok that's an issue
I'm rooked III what the heck and queen
83 is got Queen g2 unfortunately
threatening made on g7 whom
I can go to be 60 this one
yeah I'm breaking up the long diagonal
but he's getting stuff going on his own
unfortunately hmm oh my hmm I lose the
scale that would be awful after having
that fantastic position earlier he was
just a complete win for black but I
didn't do it right it's still not easy
still not easy maybe you can take I
don't see anything bad happening on the
long diagonal at the moment
okay you cannot take age 69 f 2 okay
maybe you can stand that I have not G 3
though Nigeria king gee 190 to check
that should lead to a check at the end
okay so at the end he will be non time
or what probably yeah have a winning
position again but no time on the clock
okay Wow who god did I did I ever made
did I ever made I don't know I I did no
time whatever what's that chick made I
don't didn't Queen g1 there was the maid
I don't know I didn't see it made oh I
got a back to back against mr. Fong tozi
here again let's go for the Trump
Oh some aggressively minded
so I've got a very nice position
strategically here with this pawns week
but there is something going on on the
dark square so we might have some play
there against my my king in the long run
with Nigerian stuff like that my night
only two is pretty awful how do I get
how do I get it improved it's not so
easy right here let's start with this ya
hear the compensation for giving up the
bishop is the pawn structure I've got a
decent very young pneumonias pawn
structure while blacks pawn structure is
not that great even though here black
has certainly ok
meth doc asks what has been the most
seemingly unsound opening played in a
serious event that's tough to say I mean
certainly I think nowadays people are
far more willing to to play openings
that were considered a bit unsound years
ago for example though the the Dutch
defense the Dutch defense Leningrad i
think has gained some some credit in
recent years has been played by many
strong players yeah like you Carlton
Nakamura caruana and yeah someone just
pointed out that cars and has played the
pond siani opening in one game which I
found pretty surprising it's just not a
very good opening okay I'm taking e6
looks wrong hmm don't have a clear idea
what to do maybe this for tried to take
and play rook c1 the st. George opening
at the last time yeah that was played
was in that game that miles away
blundered 92 what a shame that mild
scalp of game
blended 92 yeah that miles cup of game
where they all all mention it's as often
mentioned yeah that miles won that game
what people fail to mention is that cap
off was completely winning and and
blundered something pretty badly so the
the opening in itself wasn't xyx s four
miles he had a terrible position um okay
whom he's gotten is getting Quincy to
going I have to get into an 85 I came
hmm let's go back yeah the Budapest
gambit is a playable opening it's not
great but it also it's not complete
rubbish
I ask God f6 if I go Bishop d3 that's
not good
oh man what a bad position
yeah great oh man um i would like to
have some kind of play can you give me
some awful mmm how do i get some kind of
play maybe like this you can just take
hom
maybe I can take it six and enter with
the Queen pretty awful what I played in
this game yeah looks it too Wow care
about stuff okay not really I sometimes
play the trump in blitz chess I mean
blitz you can do many things the Danish
gambit we are probably equal ish I mean
it depends e4 e5 G for ED forum sorry II
45 d 4 84 c 3 is just incorrect because
of Queen e7 and you can play the the
delayed Danish like so in the Scotch
like Knight f3 knight c6 d for ED for c3
this is some equal I think after d5 but
not more than that ok let's see if I can
win a game against mr. finger finger
slip let's go back to my old Spanish
ways yes I play that line again just for
old times sakes yeah well that's a going
gambit what I said is a delete Danish
government it's kind of similar
yeah that's the Chi Goren again but I
can already tell you that I'll be fine
in this game if white is not going for
one or two for one or two particular
lines then this line is totally fine for
me and this is not one of the lines that
I feel very uncomfortable with I'll be
totally fine him and not the time that's
the big advantage of that line I have
played it like a million times and no
I'm blundering a piece I'm in such an
idiot come on and I'm not blundering a
piece he does not have before played yet
okay i was thinking i blundered a piece
but i didn't ok everything's cool ok the
position is ok I'm totally fine with
this mmm Bishop d8 wasn't strictly
necessary
I can go before in this position the
difficult decision I do that hoping that
he goes see form he shouldn't but you
have to give him some possibilities to
go wrong c4 is not terrible for white
but something that I don't mind to see
my next idea what people should be 7f
eight age six my cup may I already had
my coffee earlier okay he did it close
the whole thing
yeah I'm going to trade off my dark
squared bishop here um the end of the
plan with the light squared Bishop isn't
clear
yeah the good thing is a plate dislike
so often I cannot have lost count it's
it's difficult though to do something
something great iam it's a fantastic
opening to play on play on on time which
I usually don't do can can can you
please stop the religious kind of stuff
decision at that's leading nowhere okay
I'm going for Queen to a six
it's difficult to not trade queens and
now I can I have a couple of ideas
mostly f5 at the right moment I can also
try to get pieces around 28 and night to
a 5 not sure that this helps much though
I can get a night to a 5 12 B 6 not
doing much so I'm going to bring that
night around to e7 the other two g7 you
see going for f4 I would be interesting
yeah there is no German opening even
though I'm even though there is a the
two nights defense sometimes it's called
the Prussian defense so what this is
almost German and there was a fun fun
joke that they should get rename the
French defense and call it the the
german defence because so many German
players played it yeah why does blunder
Deponia I'm winning one of the ports and
not the time yeah that is why I'm still
playing this opening it's not a great
line but I know it so well in blitz that
I can play a million moves in no time ok
this was not planned hmm didn't see that
coming ok I can get the night over to a
five
hmm
high five doesn't seem to work easily
and okay may I see that that was weird
that it worked
I don't see a win unfortunately but I
don't see when King do 3s saving the day
for him here yeah what do you think you
can vote should I try to win otay why
should I offer him a draw them the
position is a draw oh maybe it's not
oh man so I have to win on time mmm I
said that's not a draw right ye should
should win some Moroccan what do you
think draw okay i'm going to offer okay
we draw we drew that game hmm it was bad
I should have just won that game that
was a very good position but anyway
isn't cards but in Germany no it's not
that's in the Czech Republic it's
Karlovy Vary nowadays it was some i
think was part of the the
austrian-hungarian own Empire the Empire
said right the double kingdom Oh double
kingdoms probably wrong okay anyway i'm
playing haga he is going i have his this
be porn guy i'm just going to play
quickly here he's back to a normal
reading oh really okay
it's normally not such a great idea to
play with b5 and Bishop to be seven so
we'll see we'll see what is up to do a
monarchy yeah okay I don't use the wood
background with bookshelves because I CC
wants me to use that background it's not
my choice ha gay okay yeah I know I mean
I know it's wrong I know that I'm doing
it wrong but I have a hard time to do it
correctly yeah the Kings Indian attack
is a decent line against the French can
do that it's not brilliant but its its
its its playable
yeah Congrats he's getting the night to
be three where does exactly nothing yeah
that that kind of talk probably will
blow up in my face later I just think
that this is no good and to be perfectly
honest for white so what's to do here I
have to get the M get the F porn rolling
gather toilet variation there is a
toilet variation in the Sicilian it is
one of the less glamorous names the
hillbilly attack yeah there's one one
one rule about opening names there's
absolutely no opening named after an
animal animal that is any good I think
okay the head shock maybe but nothing
nothing yeah there's the vulture or what
whatever and they're all rubbish so I'm
going at five okay you can go google
there I don't mind take that pawn and
let's see how to how to attack them
probably night over to f4 or something
like that well rang a tang yeah okay the
boots opening is named after Henry bird
that's too it's not not an animal okay
Mia 92 and he would probably just
sacrifice the exchange it's the problem
okay maybe let's do it like that I'm
unsure about my nightie to move but
we'll see
so I'm opening up the center here the
monkeys bum yeah this also yeah it's the
dragon an animal isn't that just like
isn't that like a fairy tale figure or
something like that fairy tale creature
it's not strictly an animal with dragon
so what is this it's just total mess
right now i can i'll just take that pawn
them and see what the h pawn can do for
me ok he's happy to put his queen
somewhere somewhere out in the open so
i'm going to get this attack going here
let's see like here for g6 set looks
pretty dangerous i mean you can take c3
but we'll see what happens that's
definitely more with simon williams
positions than just explain position in
fact it will see
oh that's a move that I didn't didn't
have on the radar that much wow that's
not going to work I don't believe it
giving me a whole rook on g8 okay the
position is a complete mess still so he
can still hope for for things to happen
okay um something hanging I think I can
take think I have to go get one then
what is the kangaroo defense I heard
about that the kangaroo
gather Frankenstein variation but the
frank enstein is not an animal some
night to see five what a crazy position
that is hanging let's go back Wow don't
tell me don't tell me I've blundered
this bloody game that would be a real
shame oh my god i didn't see night she's
night 93 at all
oh what a shame
yeah I have no moves oh my god it was aa
from that position amazing I was just a
rook up here I mean it was crazy but
still and I'm in a million pin sets the
worst part you might blunder stuff back
I mean he's always capable of doing that
reading the Queen down what are you
doing here mr. Hogg a Quincy five coming
how do I get this Bishop into the game
I came here for very long time poo oh my
god so I somehow I don't know how I got
one that came so let's play one more and
that's the end of it let's try something
something funky against mr. dem dem gen
something what can we do maybe some
Kings Indian that always not always but
often leads to wacky stuff I don't play
the exchange please ok so let's see the
before line I have an old line here that
I hit that as sometimes playing blitz
them I know that looks very weird but
it's not so bad
always taking a long while now
where was the katie melua reference I
don't get it someone in the I don't know
why really i mean i know her but not not
the music or anything wow it takes ages
for this
yeah I'm sorry for them that I cannot
ban at the moment I really should get
the rights there from the ICC
come on what are you doing there I mean
you just shop on the queenside that's
what you do in dec in the king's indian
I mean the black player is extremely
easy you just yeah everything forward
this this kind of game is what is why
I'm always a bit skeptical about the
classical Kings Indian is wide because
you know blacks play is pretty easy you
just shove everything forward and hope
for the best no I don't play bridge I
don't even know the rules it's supposed
to be very interesting but I'm not even
knowing the the basic rules them so
let's see yeah i will definitely have
more rights the next next week
yeah I think I'm going g3 now it's it
looks like I've got the best anti Kings
in your defense to play I don't know if
you want to be on the safe side it's not
a better idea to play the fianchetto
variation it's very safe and in in most
cases still preserves chances for an
advantage
so I'm going to
yeah backgammon assaults is supposed to
be quite interesting but i don't i don't
really know it in any any detail so
let's see I've got quite quite some
pieces there on is king but doesn't seem
to win yet how would you do it Scott
Roxy one works is seven still coming up
so I'm not sure if I can already do
something drastic nigeria's such a move
let's do that
that also controls the C 1 square for
our for moment is got that one yeah I
only saw it now that would have saw that
earlier probably would have avoided that
line he's just going to lose on time
it's not even speeding up what do we had
way to play and it's definitely not an
engine I mean
yeah you know some time varies very
straight very strange okay so guys I
hope you enjoyed enjoyed the show got a
couple of minutes overtime in and I can
also show you that next next time I'll
be there with what rights to to bend
people okay so i hope you have a good
rest of the of your monday wherever you
I it will be a couple of hours or just
one hour in my case thanks for watching
I'll be back next week and also back on
sunday i think with sunday right to
cover the london chest classics ok guys
bye